[Musique]
elle se voulait voir les frères c'est
très simple je gérais des gens dans la
rue on leur pose des questions sans
intérêt et pendant qu'ils nous répondent
on va vite se changer on s'habille comme
à peu près 1 c'est pas non plus
dreamworks regarder j'en ai eu beaucoup
ça super bien c'est parfois douter c'est
en inédit bah oui bah bien sûr on est
vendredi vendredi c'est à essayer
tournée m'ont aidé à monter là ya pas
une vie sûre dans la région française
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez transports en
commun par exemple il faut qu'ils sont
parfaits c'est très utile même si
j'utilise pas souvent parce que je
marche beaucoup
mais j'étais encore à long de la semaine
dernière et je peux vous dire qu'ils
sont beaucoup plus pratique le maillage
est beaucoup plus serré et c'est très
utile et batterie en pense quoi
mon frère est un cas social et galatée t
elle et gourcuff a donné qu'ils ont
parlé des transports en commun parisiens
la défense c'est pourquoi pour cyril
hanouna bel et bien c'est vrai c'est pas
le truc que je prends souvent puisque
comme je fais châtelet boulogne en est
trop simple et votre à elle en pense
quoi
pardon votre frère il en pense quoi j'ai
pas de frère
tu reviendrais
salut transport moi pareil ça me gonfle
de temps à autre ça dépend l'appareil et
quatre top mois plus tard salut j'ai
plein de trucs que je trouve qu'ils sont
pas mal mais il ya certaines métro qui
fonctionne pas très bien comme la ligne
6 qui a tout le temps des problèmes
presque tous les jours donc lrr quoi et
votre choix en pense quoi
mccain il m'a fait l'amour tempête mais
laisse tomber tu as nancy des souhaits
chalet de la part de ce mondial est
relou ça va toi noël toi super je
racontais je fais bouillir hier soir
mais les seconds derrière deux voyons ça
lui même appareil comme pour saluer par
heymans m avec ma soeur on est les deux
mêmes chaud bouillant taille
rien
[Musique]
j'allais pas terminée mais au delà de
moi je suis au delà de cléon ça se
trouve c'est d'une connerie formidable a
nommé merci tu adores
[Applaudissements]